Loki kills the Avengers in Marvel Comics
and those aren't the only ones he kills
a bunch of other people too this story
is amazing so this story literally opens
up with Loki explaining how he's
captured or killed every single Avenger
in the universe and what he does is he
chains up the hammer of Thor we'll find
out what happened to Thor here in a
little while Captain America who was
frozen in ice and never discovered was
tossed into yotenheim the land of the
frost Giants Tony Stark is stuck in a
prison and he's basically an alcoholic
this guy killed every single inhuman on
the planet which is fine because nobody
cares about them he sacked wakanda he
sent anybody who was a Ghost Rider off
to muspelheim the land of cerder which
is basically the Asgardian version of
hell and then he killed every single
other person on Earth with powers the
X-Men Alpha flight the whole nine yards
so the question has to be asked why in
the world is he even doing this in the
first place so the thing to understand
about this version of Loki is that in in
the reality that he lives in Thor did
exist but died as a child and in fact he
died when he was first trying to learn
how to use his hammer it flew him into
the sun and it killed him and so Loki in
turn seized control of the Asgardian
Throne of Asgard he had Odin shipped off
as a slave to yotenheim the land of the
frost Giants where he presumably stayed
Evermore but then Loki in turn realized
there was no sense of fulfillment here
and so what he did is he started
reaching out to different iterations of
himself across the Multiverse and for a
time they would talk and have
conversations and so on but almost
immediately after meeting each other
that alternate reality version of Loki
would try to kill him because that's
what Loki's do and that's what this
version of Loki started to realize every
alternate reality version of himself
that he met was just a crazy guy who
tried to kill anybody that he perceived
to be a threat so then he started asking
the question am I like this in every
other universe so then he started
leaving his universe and traveling to
other realities and secretly spying on
those alternate versions of Loki and
this did two things number one it
confirmed he is a villain in pretty much
every Universe in the Multiverse and
number two he's always defeated by The
Avengers not only that he's the reason
why the Avengers even come together in
the first place and so in order to
solidify his rule over Earth and
eliminate anybody who would stand in his
way he killed all the different Avengers
and pretty much every superpowered being
on Earth here's the kicker to this Loki
failed to realize that he himself was
not the only threat that the Avengers
had to face off against over the course
of their time on Earth in any one
particular Universe they would also have
to face off against Galactus and the
celestials Thanos with or without The
Infinity Gauntlet Red Skull with a
Cosmic Cube Gore the god butcher now
despite how it's depicted here I doubt
all these guys showed up on Earth at one
time to fight Loki it would be amazing
if they did but what Loki says is
through his power of mysticism which is
astronomical he wiped these guys out now
assuming he became the new sorcerer
Supreme after presumably killing Doctor
Strange that's entirely possible because
people underestimate how insanely
powerful Stephen Strange is but in doing
this Loki started to realize he became
the very villain that he despised the
most so he tried to kill himself he
literally flew into the sun because his
rationale was if the sun killed four the
sun would kill him and it did then he
wakes up in the god Quarry what's the
god Quarry so the god Quarry is both a
source of god-like power as well as the
home of the multiversal Infinity Stones
the way this works in Marvel is that
those gods and goddesses out there who
exist when they die their bodies travel
to the god Quarry and it serves as a
kind of graveyard but within the Quarry
itself resides the first firmament also
known as the first Universe the power of
the first firmament is astronomical it
certainly exceeds the abilities of any
Infinity Gauntlet in any one particular
universe and the power of the first
firmament may very well even exceed the
power of the Living Tribunal but within
the god Quarry is also the multiversal
Infinity Stones which is to say that
when the Multiverse came into existence
the stones came into existence in the
Quarry and they were dispersed across
the Multiverse which is how you get an
Infinity Stones in every different
reality now those individuals who
approach the god Quarry and try to
attain its power will be given a test if
they fail they'll return to Stone and
trapped forever if they succeed they'll
attain the power of the first firmament
and effectively become God Loki's not
really looking for either and in fact
he's really just looking to die here but
the god Quarry rejects his attempts to
die and then he realizes he's
effectively stuck here and so in coming
to the realization that he's always the
reason why the Avengers Assemble even if
for no other reason than to somehow
defeat him he decides he should start
forming a multiversal Avengers team
should anything go awry within the
Multiverse that would lead to a team of
that caliber now this initially started
out with what were called the death
locks which is to say some individuals
seeking the god Quarry lands here or
stumbles across this place not knowing
what it is they're essentially trapped
and they ultimately die Loki would
resurrect them using his extreme power
and then would turn them into a kind of
Cyborg and they would go out into the
Multiverse as a kind of police officer
patrolling their own individual sector
but what ended up happening here is that
in an alternate universe a version of
Doctor Doom started working with a
version of Mephisto and what they did is
they started building a team that would
serve the purpose of going from one
reality to the next and destroying the
Avengers on that world specifically what
were called the primordial Avengers why
were they called that because in Marvel
Comics one of the other editions they
have when it comes to the Avengers is
that you had what were called Avengers 1
Million BC which is to say a team with
like Odin and the Phoenix Force the very
first black panther and that team
basically set the groundwork for what
would later become the Avengers in the
modern era if that team's destroyed the
Avengers never exist and the earth falls
to a terrible fate and that's what Dr
Doom and his guys were doing they were
killing the old Avengers from 1 Million
BC and preventing the rise of
superheroes in the modern era now what
ends up going on is that Loki starts to
realize what's happening across the
Multiverse this initially happens when a
portion of doctor Doom's Army invades
the god Quarry seeking to attain the
power of the first firmament Loki
responds obliterates all these guys and
then goes into the Multiverse to find
out what's going on he's ultimately
trapped by different versions of
Mephisto known as the Council of red and
he pretty much overpowers all of them
and then is able to take them out it's
not the entire Council but a pretty good
chunk of it which kill killing multiple
versions of Mephisto at one time is
pretty astronomical in terms of power
but in returning to the god Quarry he's
met with the multiversal Avengers that
have been recruited by the surviving
death locks that hadn't been destroyed
by Dr Doom's forces and so the team does
not trust Loki because in their mind
he's just a version of Loki who always
does what Loki does but what he ends up
doing is spilling the beans to the
entirety of the Avengers in the hopes
that they would somehow learn to trust
him and ultimately what they end up
realizing is he's their only real chance
at being able to defeat the forces of
Doctor Doom that without this version of
Loki effectively all hope is lost and so
what they end up doing is trusting him
tentatively but in order to build that
trust up Loki actually expands the
roster of the Avengers he ends up
bringing in all these variants of
Avengers from across the Multiverse by
opening a portal which looks
astonishingly similar to the one that
doctor strange uses in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and so what you get
is this colossal multiversal Avengers
team led by Loki now operating under the
name Avengers Prime that are running
headlong into a war against the forces
of Doctor Doom and his entire Army of
antithesis villains to The Avengers with
that being said we're going to bring
this to an end if you guys want to get
caught up on everything related to The
Avengers make sure you guys click the
link to this video and I will catch you
all later
peace